my name is John Folse I'm director of
user interfaces of Wolfram research and
I'm giving a talk on which I've titled a
meditation on computable notebooks and
miscellaneous thoughts and I'm talking
principally about the future of the
Wolfram system front end and the future
of notebook technologies at large thank
you
so if I wanted to write my own service
connection is there way
thank I often get the sense that people
get pulled into open source by wanting
to scratch some small itch they have and
often time that's a little bit harder
than it could be in mathematica the
specific example I have is it be nice to
develop an obsession syntax tree for
Mathematica and start linting it and
making code quality judgments of my code
but as soon as I have to do that I have
to start worrying about the license
manager and the license manager on my
friend's machine and is adam going to
bring up the license manager correctly
and stuff like that so the very small
problems or you just need to do one
thing and then share it can sometimes be
harder than it might otherwise be and
i've got nothing no suggestions for that
but
sort of trip on on some of that I was I
was thinking for some of the things that
I've seen demonstrations of there's lots
of data that isn't necessarily installed
with Wolfram install and if I was
publishing papers or something and I
needed to or trying to support customers
on some old version of a product I'd
written in Mathematica and I wanted to
be sure that things would stay the same
and keep working the same I would wonder
if there was some way to connect to the
old version of that data set or
something at Wolfram
I was just gonna comment maybe a little
bit on your security audit piece the and
I apologized to dragging this in a
certain company a certain direction here
but maybe it's relevant so you know if I
wanted to take your software package
known as Mathematica and take it to
certain places in my customer set they
would expect a whole Legion of security
checks and because I don't really own
your code I can't do that right yet
there's countless other packages that
have been already certified for use in
those environments so there you know
there are standard processes and to some
extent you could help yourself as a
company by making it better known as to
what levels of security checks and
honest have you already gone through you
know maybe you need to protect those in
some way and so you have to follow a
certain process to request the kind of
documentation but it would it would be
helpful if if we follow these three or
seven steps here you can get to the
document that is a PDF that certifies
that this version was you know certified
in this environment you know that kind
of thing then we could perhaps get
further down the road quicker
yeah well I was going to ask
specifically are we talking military or
or what domain good because for example
I mean the Air Force is one of our
customers and they they will let us know
if we one of their certification
standards to partially answer your
question
so I was specifically thinking of the
case of the US government right and the
US government's a big thing and each
essentially each of the military
services Air Force being one of those
have their own processes so if you you
say let's for example hypothetical let's
say that the wolfram version X was
certified for the US Air Force as of
this date that is not going to carry
like any water with any of the other
services pretty much right
[Music]
well I mean
US government's a big thing right and
just DoD is a big thing but having some
way to be able to sort of say you know
what wouldn't perhaps carry water is hey
this product two years ago was certified
with one of the military services and
that at least gives the creditors some
positive vibe that this has a chance
with some other service right it's not
it's not going they're not going to just
sort of reciprocity take the Air Force's
certification right there but they they
will then perhaps say okay this can be
done and you know you can start moving
in that drug these processes take a long
time I'm here to tell you it's sort of a
second an anecdote but from what I've
heard some of the most strenuous
certification has actually been in the
financial industry I know someone who
has customers who won't run anything
that they don't have a complete copy of
the source code of
I think this wasn't necessarily an open
source requirement you can write a
contract with them to give them the
source code and not have it open
big ports can across your software and
did or did not open
so no of course that's
good collaboration environments
to get the support that I would expect
and and you know that means
you know it should be a huge barrier if
I want other people to be able to build
my product
that should not be hard
and I think that
we're not
fundamentally challenged there but there
are lots of little pain points that we
run into
the lack of syntax highlighting the lack
of being able to create you notebooks
the fact that the process for assembling
a packet which is kind of you know
deployment is undocumented and in some
cases actually building
not standardized at all
so I mean this is one of the areas that
I'm that I'm working in and if that's
that's a pain point for you or you have
thoughts or ideas about that I'd love to
hear that and then the other is just
looking at places inside the company
where it's like you know what
what have you used for interesting to
take portions of our product
put it out there for people to see you
know completely transparently would that
be interesting or would that be just the
waste of time because you know it does
it does consume time and ultimately I
think it's a difficult proposition the
swing that the entire product is
commitee out there
the I mean you know it's the nature you
know running a software business it's
very challenging to you know to do so if
your entire product is out there you
know in source form for everyone to use
but there are a lot of portions of our
product which I think that you know III
think that we could say
that's a thing that can be done so these
are things that I think
we're not totally constrained on time
here but we probably should be wrapping
up later but I'd like to get
John in that last comment is why I'm
interested in I think that there's a
couple of side effects if much more of
the code was exposed firstly users would
have examples of best practice out there
for their own coding they'd also be able
to take code snippets which would show
them how to do things that would require
that code to be well documented and
presented there but which I assume it is
internally though I know and not all of
it is but I think that that would be an
excellent thing and one of the
communities I'm involved with is
astronomy and astrophysics and basically
they are totally using Python now
they're 30 40 % used Python and it's the
open source side of it that they got
burnt with ideal Mathematica be an ideal
tool for them some of them use it as a
side tool but they all use Python and I
think
yeah I guess I'd echo what you talked
about at the top of the list was get
integration I've seen a huge amount of
lift and I work at a financial data
scientist sharing Jupiter notebook so I
get up and the fact that it has the
renderer available in github became a
huge source of lift for just Jupiter
adoption across the board and I know the
Zeppelin team is working on something
similar for that Apache project so it
might be something that I mean knowing
that people are already versioning their
notebooks in get being able to then
render an or some subset of the notebook
in order you know the qualified version
of the language be renderable and yet I
think would give it you know an
interesting lift certainly given that
there's so much Enterprise github
internally as well as obviously the
github comm
basis
in terms of cost and I wasn't convinced
that they were the Rolls Royce in terms
of performance but they definitely were
in terms of cost as compared to
but yeah so I'm definitely curious to
hear
you know when certainly when we look
projects I mean github is a monster
so I like that question why don't we
pull the audience on some things how
many of you work at Mathematica or on
Mathematica or on alpha
how many have projects on public github
how many use github at work how many of
those are github Enterprise how many of
yous other things
perforce what else should I be asking
how much of the room has used Jupiter
and likes it
oh I know it's the competition I'm just
how many of you use what is the what is
the official name for dot WL or dot
m-files package files how many of you
have written a Pacolet
how many of you have given those packets
to other people to use
okay so are there demonstrations on the
demonstration page that make use of more
than just Mathematica that would be a
good example right show me a piece of
code that is making use of Mathematica
and making use of other stuff
so I I have a little experience with
Python but I do have experience with our
and I like ma I was wonder how much
could we open source and maintain the
business model because I I look at our
and it's kind of terrible I and you know
such I would say I'm a you would say I'm
amazed that people use it like the
quality of the code is often terrible in
it and I think there's a business model
of like people pay for people to write
code that is okay like I think that is a
business model so I and I have I don't
know how good are the our code is out
there but I assume that the one is okay
is because someone's gang paid to do it
properly I assume so I I kind of think
that that's that's kind of the the the
the big the the main point of the
question like I if we could have
everything open source in the sense that
like it would and and still have a
business model I think it would
obviously be be better but like how can
we how much can we open source how how
much do people value open source of
equality for instance because people use
MATLAB as well which is no open source
and it's super expensive for many things
but it it works and you know when people
get paid to do that that that job in I
mean I don't have the answer just like
this is this is what's running through
my head I guess
so when we put stuff in our
yeah just two questions so Wayne's about
open data are we curating like a Bitcoin
transaction data online which is I think
as a free plus I think mathematic okay
plus we have like lots of good
statistical package and I think
mathematic is pretty Wolfram language
and I was very good at all kinds of
financial related like functionalities
then we like just release some tutorial
to show people how to do trading with
the Mathematica I'll do with the Wolfram
language armpit coins and other like
crypto currencies I think it's now very
hot area link broker blockchain stuff so
just open this project and I encourage
people to use method or from language as
a you know to to to developer platform
yeah other one is about the cloud the
platform even though we have a like
internal cloud the Wolfram cloud but I
think we can also add packages like open
source packages for a user to connect
Mathematica to AWS or Ezzor because we
have the Java jelling and the net link
develop already so it's maybe extra
layer of API is to to do the ultimate
automation process with from within
Wolfram language
so John we're about 20 minutes past if
you want to take more questions we can
it's up to you sure a kind of small
suggestion when talking about making
decisions about what to open-source and
how and why one thing that I've seen
used very very compellingly is Wardley
mapping just to decide like which which
of the things that we have built our
commodities which of the things we've
built can we can we push our competition
around by providing free as open source
to help people which things are our core
competencies that we should really keep
under lock and key good to think about